Have a wonderful good evening, dear
guests, ladies and gentlemen, I would
like to welcome you to the climate Lab
num before I was quite
surprised myself that this is already the fourth
the climate Lab takes place every few months
its event of the clan with
change Center Berlin Brandenburg von
Berliner  scientific institution and
we look at what's
going on in the scientific landscape and
what
solutions we have for the climate crisis here in
Berlin and Brandenburg, one solution
is to talk about the topic,
that's why
we're talking about climate
communication today, I'm particularly enthusiastic about that
because we deal with
klimafakten.de and every day with
climate communication
and
climate communication that sounds relatively
special maybe a bit
niche we will also
talk about what that actually is and what
you can hope for from it at the beginning
of the discussion
I was very naive myself this naivety
dealing with the topic is also reflected
a bit in the name of our
project Climate Facts, we thought
when we started 11 years ago,
well, we have a lot of
knowledge from science about
climate change and we simply have to give people a try
enlighten them and if they then
have the knowledge and if we above
all don't know that and have
fought the disinformation and the lies,
then yes, then we will do
climate protection and in the spirit of Ms.
Rotter as a
recycling management expert, I
always have a wonderful
cloth bag with me to go shopping with  and
this fabric bag here is from the
German climate consortium, which is the
umbrella organization for climate research in
Germany and there is a
saying on it that I don’t think is quite wonderful: physics
cannot be negotiated the saying
is really good because it’s true, but of course
the saying
also contains a big
problem  because societies are
organized in such a way that we are constantly negotiating
and that we don't really
allow ourselves to be forced into anything by physics, or
at least don't want to be forced into doing anything
Please applause for
Jana Hoppmann
[Applause]
Jana, I'm glad you're talking to us right away
because
it's great that we work together with some of the people we're getting to
know tonight
Jana is also one of them
Jana Hoppmann is a social and
environmental psychologist, she has a degree at the Free University
[Music]
studied social economics and organizational psychology and
she is a social entrepreneur, she
founded small with mind, a
consulting company, a non-profit,
which helps with klimak communication and
what I really like is the saying
on the climate website,
which says that powerlessness was yesterday
and  That fits perfectly with the fact that when
we ask the Germans what is your
feeling
with regard to climate protection and
climate policy, then above all the
feeling of helplessness and I think
you have ideas on how to deal with it
and we want to hear them now, so
welcome Jana
me  Just look ah wonderful now
I can also speak out loud
thank you all
very much for being here we will test very briefly whether everything
is working wonderful thank you for
the invitation I now have the great
opportunity to fill the next 15 minutes with you
and under the
big question how do we get from
dreaming to action
why should this be on the topic of
climate communication right now we have
just felt the role of facts a
bit classified
so we will go into it much more deeply
so how do we get it  towards the
topic of climate protection not only
to develop dreams not only to
impart knowledge not to stop with my knowledge
but to get into
action that's what it's all about in the end with
climate protection no just talking
doesn't help us but in the end we want to
see action then um
so far again  a few keywords
about me and then it starts straight away
what has been bothering me personally for a long time
and the
wonderful thing about karel's introduction is
the fainting I almost
despaired of my own fainting
over many years during my studies
I was involved in a variety of ways  On
the subject of sustainability, but I've always
had the feeling that, compared to the
crises we have, my own
options for action are incredibly small
and unfortunately I'm not the only one who thinks that,
or not only I thought that, but
as I said, that's one of the
basic phenomena that we're
current in psychology
When it comes to the climate crisis in Germany, there is
helplessness, which means that
answers are needed as to how we deal with it
and to put it another way,
from grandma out there, what do we
actually want to get into, I would say we
should get into a world of
self-efficacy if we  that in the
psychology of the collective kind,
not only do we have the feeling of being
able to make a difference on our own, but in the
best case we have the feeling of being able to make a difference in the
group together in the collective in
society, which
means we have to move towards the topic of
climate protection  and how do we get
there it's all about right now and we're
clear with my belief
that it's worth
using I think the world of climate justice is worthwhile
people have the feeling are
powerful but also actually about the feeling about
communication about action
become powerful
I have brought you six barriers
that prevent us from acting
and at the same time
can motivate us, i.e. six
psychological starting points and
I will go straight to the first one
we are at an event
about science
science communication I would like to talk to
you directly  take the first assumption
and that is the importance of knowledge well the
question is so what role does
knowing what it really matter
and we see it mattered relatively little
because the problem is we are
much more irrational than we all think
we often assume um  so on the
subject of home economics we would
rational behavior no at least as
great an influence as our knowledge
or our reasonable
approaches rational considerations
between costs and benefits
also have our emotions and identities
and that is exactly why I find
a lot more space here in this lecture so
we are  for irrational than
we think knowledge is not enough
and the big point at this point is
also the question is how do we evaluate
the knowledge or we will we the
information the facts lay the
data situation seems significant to us
that depends very much on
together with the knowledge is much more exciting in terms of risk
perception
when it comes to when people take
action
because a big barrier is when we
have the feeling that the climate crisis is just
very far away on many levels
far away in terms of time in mind
from geographic social this is a
poor country problem or
actually hypothetical so in terms of
uncertainty if you
look at it scientifically the
accuracy or inaccuracy of data
but sometimes it is
interpreted as unsafe in society
so unfortunately
we don’t have to make the assumption at all
deal with that you
just don't know exactly yet, then
you should present it again ten years later,
precisely because we as
humans perceive this data situation as irrelevant
or the climate crisis with its
findings as not so significant
we have to get away from it we can
do it  we should create an emotional
closeness on precisely these levels,
it is about a crisis that
is here now, we are also
affected and there is a very clear
scientific consensus
so well, then we may have
clarified the emotional closeness, but then it is so
widespread  that's
still not enough for a long time because we have
certainly recognized that in our everyday life
an absolute
inconsistency are actually so
torn
between beliefs
attitudes ne maybe also
climate-protecting beliefs we
also say it is really important to me
maybe too  start in the sense of I
am a good climate protector but our
behavior does not always look
like it fits together exactly there
maybe we build a new
home with a lot of steel and
cement or we fly far away on
vacation or we create  it's also
not going to the Fridays for future demo after all
because our work, our
independence or something similar
is perhaps more important to us and this
cognitive dissonance, this
contradiction in ourselves, which is
difficult to overcome through
communication, well, it's going to be
discussed again in the same way as we are
that can then be resolved, but first of all
we want to resolve this
dissonance, this contradiction within ourselves,
we then have a variety of
starting points, such a small teaser, we
deny our responsibility so that,
as I said, then everything
fits together again, we
no longer experience this contradiction,
we perhaps compensate  even with
so-called consonant behaviors
for that I live vegan then my
living on 200 square meters is okay
we all know that from our everyday life no that
's an everyday phenomenon that
doesn't just happen with a minority
of society
or how ignore and forget those
are the classic
approaches  what we often
wish for in a conversation when we
approach it naively is we just want
the other person to change their behavior
says ok then I just use
sustainable materials and
my house isn't that easy for me now
we see here  this
last approach point and could
solve as elevator is the least likely
because it is incredibly uncomfortable for us
as humans to implement
what we need instead we need to
put in place a structure because as said
and resolve cognitive dissonance
that create behavior that is
consistent with  our values ​​is as
easy as possible to implement is because
individual conversations are not enough yet
another important point is the
question of social recognition or
social rejection so now let's go
into the topic of identity we are
people embedded in larger systems
with our neighbor with our
family  our girlfriends and all
of them have an incredibly great
influence on us
you can see that in
a meta-analysis from today Erdal, who
asked himself how is it
actually how can we
explain that some people
deny the climate crisis and others
you can't guess, especially in the context of
this event, it's
simply because of the knowledge, but
certain information is missing, we have to
clarify, they need more
science communication, they do
n't look at my messages closely, no,
the answer was a completely different one, his
influencing factors on who is
running the climate crisis  and who weren't were
aspects of the social social
identity identification the
sense of community so
individualistic values ​​climate deniers
belonging to conservative
parties and the last one has to
understand the framework these are studies that are
mainly implemented in the USA
ne belief in the
American free market economy  who
live here quite clearly people and
does not happen because I lack the knowledge
or I have simply
not experienced this phenomenon but it is very
much related to how I trust who do
I believe who is important to me
where do I get the information from,
i.e. climate protection  only works in a team we
have to support each other as a community as a
society as a team, no matter how small
this topic is and
only with social recognition instead of
social rejection can we really achieve climate protection
it is important
to consider a few aspects here, we often want
values  change that's rather unfavorable
or impractical I'll just call it
because it's very difficult Values
that are relatively stable over
our life can adapt a bit through
critical life events, so
if something very drastic
happens in life,
but usually  they
develop through childhood
and adolescence, that means we should
actually work more with the values
that our counterpart or our larger
target group brings with them and demands that
we consider how do I take the person with us
now, starting from these values, we
should consider who our
ambassadors might be  am I not
the right ambassador
to activate or address another person
maybe it is someone
else who just has much better access
and unfortunately sustainability is very important at the moment
it is something that encounters social
rejection we have to create it
together for the community and social
norms  Sustainability exists from
in the municipality to in partnership
and to the company.
Another aspect is the question of
feelings, so how do I
actually experience the climate crisis emotionally and
what does that have to do with my actions
or maybe with
my obstacles  The topic of
self-efficacy we've already
started with is a very, very important
aspect and we're going to take a closer look at it
Climate crisis real because when we
go through our everyday life we ​​try what
we call
emotion regulation in psychology to have as many pleasant
experiences as
possible well well some do it a
bit excessively and others a
bit mildly but basically
we want to experience pleasant feelings
unpleasant rather less is okay and
understandable from the perspective of
mental health no if we were
all experiencing unpleasant feelings all the time now
we would be
sad in bed at some point and wouldn’t
get out at all but in a time of
crisis in which it’s not just about that
avoiding unpleasant emotions
but rather working with this problem
and finding one's way around in a world finding a
solution is really
dramatic because we have to get people
to expose themselves to unpleasant feelings and move on from there,
how exactly does that work based on my
experience so far and  Counseling practice
is very important because having such a
schedule in mind, depending on the
target group, it may
of course be important
to start with risk communication first,
so to say yes, of course we have a
dramatic situation, but I’m
assuming if I’ll just tell you now
If I were to give a 15-minute
lecture about the drama of the climate crisis
and then
ask questions before and after how motivated you are
to do something, then I guess it
might even
backfire or at least
not have an incredible big impact
for the future  That means after you
realize how bad it is and how
dramatically how quickly you have to treat it,
you have to get to the second stage
and because pleasant feelings arouse your
desire to act together
and also make you want to
act together in a group
in structures, no because  alone we
may only make a very small step
forward with the crisis together we can really make a difference
and in order to create self-efficacy
it is very helpful in psychological research
to visualize success in oneself I think we all
pay too little attention to what we do
actually manage in everyday life and
focus very quickly on
the next goal I can definitely do it
quite well by myself so it's important to
think about what I actually did
yesterday the day before yesterday this week
what can I be proud of
I can be satisfied with that and
We should have exactly these conversations with those
around us, so then we really
experience success that the current
and then we have more
strength to continue very important yes,
the penultimate point is actually
my favorite barrier and at
the same time a motive because I
have the feeling  We deal with
this aspect far too little and I have
the suspicion that there is a reason
why we don't get any further in many political
discussions, panels,
talk shows, because we
often come across self-esteem protection -
what exactly does self-esteem protection mean there is
first of all that we all
have the feeling  want to be able to pat ourselves on the back at the end when we
go to bed after a day
and say
I'm pretty good
actually, on the whole I'm
pretty good person and have
n't taken that many pictures at
least not that I can  I ca
n't look at myself in the mirror all day long
and that's a
phenomenon we all have, we
all
maybe even want to look a little better
than we actually are or
just experience ourselves in a positive image
and how exactly does that happen how can you
even imagine that our
information processing, i.e. how we
process information from I read something or I hear something into an action or
first get a more precise picture of it
already that is structured based on self-esteem,
so we collect
indications that promote self-esteem, well
not this newspaper article from the beginning  to the
end and not every word just as
attentively but, if necessary,
we read that where we have the feeling at the end
that is particularly good for us and our
self-image
of the day we
can go to bed and say I'm a
pretty good person too,
but that doesn't just happen to all of us
who may already
be doing a little more, it also happens
to key politicians and
executives in business and
they also say in the end
I also think I
did it quite well I would be a very good
person and if someone comes on the
talk show and you say how you
made mistakes you did
n’t fulfill your responsibilities what
happens then we raise our
walls and we also think about
it internally  are a pretty good
person and says oh no no that's
not mine found no I am I
didn't do anything wrong that's
a very important point for any kind
of conversation
and how do we get out of it
if someone feels like it  has to deal with it more closely
comes to me
um i won't send you any material i
think we really have to get to it we can
only do it if we
all ask our basic psychological needs for
autonomy,
competence and social connectedness and
exciting studies have shown or
initial approaches for everyone  It
can happen that when we
have set these basic needs for ourselves
but also for others, we are then able to
deal with information that threatens our self-worth in such a way
that we do not block it but
can then take action, but if
these three needs are not met
then  let's not
do self-esteem protection
so here's the real question on the
topic of science communication, how
can we think about self-worth?
I'd like to bring that into the discussion
and the last point before
I close is that of the inner
bastard because we introduce
ourselves  have already talked a lot about knowledge
and also some aspects that
I have presented that bring us
more in the direction of intentions so the
first big gap the first big clash
with which we don't deal enough
the second big clash but happens
between the intention to do something and
the behavior itself is a
weaker bastard classically
called how do we get there
best with social support
alone it becomes relatively difficult
best if someone else helps us and
helps us to set
realistic goals I do that too
seldom, for example, that is too
much for me  high goals in sports or
something similar and then don't even start
or actually
show planning behavior but also
breaking down habits together and supporting each other how
can I actually master setbacks
and these six aspects I would
like to give you as an impulse how do
we come from dreaming  to act these
are things that can hold us back,
but which we can also use as ingredients
to promote a socio-ecological
transformation with fun and in
community
and
so that we actually manage to
turn dreams into deeds, we deal
with successful
science communication
and I am happy  I look forward to the further
discussion,
thank you very much Jana, thank you also for the
clarification, we can obviously also
operate climate communication without
you telling us anything about the
greenhouse effect and how bad it is,
that's another take away,
maybe
thank you, I can use this beautiful device
right away  pass on to the
next two speakers, namely Andrea
Heilrat and
Clara Rodrigues Rocker Sastre, welcome
two physicists
both from the TU Berlin
[music]
and you work you are both
science communicators
both work in a project called
the project laboratory for science communication
that is funded and takes place  within the
framework of the Berlin University Alliance
and we are about to hear something about
a very interesting point. Physics tells
us something about
tipping points in the climate system, but there are
also other tipping points with which
we can perhaps avoid the physical ones,
namely the social
and political ones and
yes you have  the word and maybe
you are still waiting for it
then you can get started please
yes super thank you for this introduction we are
also very happy that we
can speak here in this context and
exactly as I said we come
from physics on the one hand
but now we do a lot of science communication  and
try
to build a bridge here,
so today we are talking about the
critical mass and how that is
related to
science communication and social
tipping points
State of a system
qualitatively changed by a
slight change in a so-called
control parameter I want to
illustrate that with the popcorn, yes we put the popcorn
in um on the stove and
nothing happens for a very long time, but when
a certain critical temperature
is reached  then the grain bursts
and in this case this process is
also irreversible it will not
go back to its original form
that has just happened once the
tipping point has been reached there is a
qualitative change in the system
in the climate crisis there are various
known tipping points
some of which are already occurring that we
can already observe one of which is
the
coral reefs and the dying of the
coral reefs
in this context I would like to talk a bit
about what is happening there
actually the control parameter
here is also the temperature so not just
the temperature there is another one too
Factors but what happens here are the
corals that live in symbiosis with algae,
the so-called zoo santanella and
these algae are very sensitive
to temperature, they can
no longer carry out photosynthesis from a water temperature of around 29 degrees,
but
the corals only survive through the photosynthesis of these algae  it
really is the work together
and support each other
but when the these algae no longer provide any more sugar they are
shed and what is known
as coral bleaching
occurs this is a process that
is potentially also reversible that only lasts
about 10 to 15 years leaves such
small or recover for themselves and
during this period the
water temperature would have to be below the
threshold value so that their own
can accumulate here again
yes but 1.5 degrees
[music]
global warming is to be expected that 70 to
90 percent of the coral reefs will die off
and by  2 degrees sooner warming,
we are at 99 percent, so it is to be
expected that there will simply be no
corals for you anymore,
which also means that one of
these complex, this complex ecosystem,
the whole biodiversity that is
happening in this coral village, that that  there is
an estimate that about half a
billion people
are also dependent on this ecosystem,
but this is not the only tipping point
that has been identified here we see a
total of 16 different points that
will happen just below 2 degrees older warming or
probably very likely  will
happen, such as the melting of
the ice, melting of grassland, which also
results in a massive increase in the water level, um, exactly, and now
I have spoken a lot about these catastrophic
or effects of these
catastrophic points in
our ecosystem, but now we want to take
another step  step back and
look at the systems in which
such tipping points occur and maybe
something good can also be so but
shortly before so these
maybe also to understand the background a bit again
because
we are physicists so these
tipping points, for example climatic ones, gives
points  are
not easy, so climate
models, i.e. extensive
computer programs, are built for this, which calculate the
future developments of the climate on
the basis of certain assumptions,
these results are not
forecasts or
predictions, but if statements are made,
so if this scenario occurs, then
many of these could happen  Modeling is based
on the assumption that the climate
is a network, i.e. a complex system
in constant change, but if we take a
step back, it
unfortunately gets a bit technical what do
you teach us from the age of 3, so what do I mean
by a complex system
in general  system consists of elements
and their relationships in the case of
climate system the elements are for
example the atmosphere the oceans and
so on and so forth the relationships
are the interactions between these
elements
in natural sciences
the complexity of these relationships has long been
put aside and only linear
Connections considered, that is,
an action is followed by a reaction
that has had a strong impact on us
industrialization but that is not
like the real world is
the real, i.e. the complex world or
general systems contain a
tremendous amount of interactions from the
most diverse and, above all,
unpredictable causes around them  to
describe one must
move away from the linear causal view and
look at things systematically all
interactions in a system are connected
and influence each other and
each other and with each other
complex systems are generally very
difficult to understand not only for
scientists but for all of us
but there are also  a complex system
that we often forget, namely our
society,
we humans are also part of such
social systems, be it through
how we behave with each other or
how we organize ourselves
within these systems there are
also complex dynamics that
are not foreseeable and the  can also bring us to
social tipping points
so maybe you know this device
yes the fax me a device that was made
by Infothek in 1974 so the first
infotex 6000 was
brought onto the open market
until the mid 80s there were only a
few thousand of them with thermal paper
works and so I don't know if
you still know them so I don't
have me the fax machine
only became available in every
home when the thermal paper was replaced by
normal writing paper
and then it went up
rapidly from the early
90s  there is hardly an office in
Germany without a fax machine so in a
short time the social
acceptance of such fax machines was enormous
so a small technical change has
led to its social tipping point in the case is such a tipping point triggered by
a small but committed
minority of people who succeed in
hiring  to change by a majority and
thus to initiate far-reaching movement in all
areas of society,
so as soon as a critical mass
is convinced, it only needs a
small,
inconspicuous trigger to set a huge
dynamic in the whole, but what are
the social tipping points that
can help us in the climate crisis  for
this we are going into a paper by
ilona-auto and her team that discusses the
potential for social tipping elements for
a carbon-neutral society,
namely in order to achieve
the goals of the Paris Agreement safely
is a global change
towards the material-neutral
social within
necessary for the next 30 years, so
we have to achieve the emission reductions quickly,
so that we can avoid exceeding
these dangerous tipping points in our
earth. the
social tipping points proposed in the paper
are based on an expert survey and literature research
necessarily
a comprehensive list of miracle solutions
but a first selection that can help us in
the development of a
transformation path
but in order to quickly reach such social
tipping points it is necessary to
understand how this can succeed
Ilona Auto and her team speak of their
couple of specific  Kind of feedback
only found in complex systems
namely positive feedback
positive feedback is a
self-reinforcing process where the values
of two or more elements
in common neither increase nor decrease
that can lead to exponential
growth
so
an example of this behavior is
the first  documented
speculation bubble Tulips these
innocent beautiful flowers that we in
the Netherlands became
a collector's item in the Netherlands so
they were cultivated in the gardens of the socially
upper classes the
prices for these
tulip bulbs rose in a short time so
that they were one of the most valuable
but became  February 19
1637 fallow demolition just like a so
self-reinforcing processin
everything can go both ways they
can lead to tipping points or
help us avoid issues how
can we use such self-reinforcing
processes and then reduce co2 emissions
in which areas of our
society should we  act
exactly in the paper six
different I'll call them
dimensions were just identified in which
such self-reinforcing processes
within society could occur
here is just in addition to the in the
energy sector just also the area of
human settlements financial markets
feedback what so information feedback
also the education system and just  the
norms and values ​​that we have already heard about today,
these are mentioned here, we
would now simply like to talk about the last
two points about the
education system and the norms and
values ​​in the context of the climate crisis.
Climate education can lead to it
that we are crossing a certain tipping point,
if more and more
people simply have this knowledge
about the climate crisis, it will also
spread further, so of course we do
n't just want to talk and act,
of course we also have to make this leap,
but if we don't
talk about it when we  If we don't have the information,
then we can't
take action either, and
since we also
come from science communication, it's
particularly important to us that, in addition to this
climate education, we also
deal with communication
itself,
because the question is also
us  do we want to
do science communication, yes,
because science communication
is also part of climate education because it
can reach a lot more target groups, not just the people
who are currently in the education system,
but a much larger
target group to share information on the one hand and give
access to information on the other
Creating greater awareness
and also stimulating
participation processes
is also important here, but at
the same time it is also important to
talk about the way in which we
can communicate about the climate, because
at this point
communication about the climate crisis plays a
special role in
science communication
science communication can be very
neutral there are certain topics that
are simply not as close to us
as our planet and here the
question is, can there
be science communication at all in the
context of the climate crisis that does not require values ​​and
norms, or does
science communication have to be
about  The moral aspects of the
climate crisis need to be considered
in our communication,
and to what extent
the question arises for us,
how can we
get into the positive feedback loop here, so how
can we not just talk about
how bad it is  whole is but how
can we do it, how can that
lead to a more positive
feedback look, i.e. more of a
feedback look that empowers so
that more people dare to
participate more people dare to
talk about the climate crisis and
to tackle them and also to perceive this
crisis in the first place,
exactly
these self-reinforcing processes
of which we are all part, so
we can all talk to each other and
we can all rather go into the
negative feedback loop or
go into the positive feedback look  in
the sense of we also have a
self-efficacy we can change something there are
options for us to act there are also
ways out of the crisis and we
can also help and support each other here
so in a way just talking is
the simplest remedy against the
Climate change so
exactly
we can so let's definitely
like the title of our
event says let's talk about it let's
try to talk
more about the climate crisis let's
try to
organize ours together like
we did in the previous one  lecture let's
learn how to
shape this communication we have
and it's already being brought to schools and
universities let's
talk about it to become a critical mass
and change things and let's
talk about it as individuals that we are
in  live in this network that everyone
has their own place and everyone has
their own perspective but above all
everyone also has a different
responsibility thank you
very much Clara thank you Andrea for
this encouraging speech I take it
with us we are all part of
the solution because  we are talking about the climate here today
and that is
a very important
maybe the most important step we
thought it was so
rich from both sides that we
make a short stopover
and maybe one
or  put a question in the other person's head
that is perhaps more of a
technical nature, something that
is not understood or something that gnaws at you
that we can clear that up briefly,
so we are not going into a
debate now, but if there are any questions of understanding
here, please ask them
If that's not the case and you ca
n't overcome a last hesitation,
then first of all thank
you very much you can sit down where you
feel comfortable we'll look at three
somewhat more compact three interesting
communication projects from Berlin's
scientific landscape  and
in the first project we get to know two
interesting
people, the first one, let me
introduce dr Alexandra Hüttl, she is a
social scientist at the Potsdam
Institute for Climate Impact Research,
she wrote her doctoral thesis
on the role of human values ​​in
sustainable consumption, so
I think that fits in perfectly with what  we have
already heard twice today and she
is
responsible she will introduce us to the second person
who is called skiara and
skiara is something that does something to us
and what it does will introduce us to Alexander
please thank you
very much I am happy to
be here and you  or just
take you with me on a journey through time into the
climate future.
It is specifically about a
climate change simulation
that is based on scientific
models of climate change
and is also interactive, which
means I can get into the
simulation and a bit far into my
own climate future
we've heard that before, it's
sometimes not so clear
what
maybe half a degree of
global warming means for me personally, so
we like to build up a certain
distance from the topic,
or we fall into the
conviction that we're not doing anything anyway
and at this point
the
climate change simulation starts a little bit Chiara that is
the developer behind it or that is the
non Prophet GmbH behind it
little Time Machine is
the official name of the product at the moment
and there is also a third question that
accompanies the simulation
and that comes from the scientific
point of view, how do we
actually get on the right path now and
that also ties in very closely with what
Klare and Andreas have already said
it is still relatively unclear what will happen
when such a social
dynamic sets in  and we might
get there, that social tipping points
occur, for example,
but I'm going to continue
with small machines for now,
the whole thing is out, but what happens you
can look at it on a computer or
mobile and you'll find yourself
in an environment where you're
certain  On
the one hand, you can
provide information on all areas of life, so what is my name, how do I live,
basically on everything that has a
bit of a
CO2 footprint,
but the other aspect is that I
can also vote on political measures,
here using the example of the CO2 tax  But it is
also integrated, for example
voting on the energy money or the
speed limit
and the third aspect of the
options for action is that you
can also exchange information about everything you do in the simulation with others
via a chat
then it's like that the actions
you  now carried out in the simulation itself
and the collective
actions of the participants are not without
consequences, so the climate is changing,
maybe you can see
it here in 43 years, maybe it looks a
bit different
and you can
also look at how the climate has changed at any time
now developed locally on my
doorstep in our 100
square kilometer
radius or how about other
parts of the world
and there is a small newsfeed
and I find out what's going on with
climate change because a bit further
to follow
and here we are  Of course we are very clear
on the level where the simulation is
trying to create awareness,
perhaps
to reduce the distance to climate change a bit,
and then the next aspect, which
is probably just as important as Jana said, is
that we also want to try a bit
far to achieve self-efficacy
through the actions in the simulation
and therefore it is first of all
shown what is my
personal contribution so let's assume
everyone would behave like me or
change their behavior
what does that actually lead to in
comparison to how  other behavior in the
simulation and that's a
bit far, so I'll say the product
is in constant further development and
there are still many things that should make it
possible to show at the end
that certain
changes in behavior make it less
likely than political
measures to do what you can  can ultimately have an influence
and to get on a good journey,
you can say yes, this is about
playing for the climate, of course we have done it
all before and looked at it,
because it actually does what it is
supposed to do, I can also do that
later  tell me more
and the third and last aspect again
in my presentation, which now answers this
first question again about social
dynamics,
which is also a third aspect,
that we have the big vision behind
the simulation and that the
data may also be used
carries out controlled experiments with it and in
turn incorporates this into
theoretical models, because we
often lack the empirical parameters
insofar as a tool for
science communication is quite clear,
because we bring people
together with scientific models
for the climate because there might also be a
bit of rethinking then
can achieve at least the hope and yes but
also a tool for science
yes we have accompanied everything so far
otherwise please
just refer you to the website for more
information it is a small project that
I am also happy about any support
and you can  Of course you are also
welcome to contact me if you have any questions
yes, thank you very much
[applause]
thank you very much Alexander Hüttl
I have a question about
how far you have already
had experience with it is that something
you are now building and still programming
or do you already have experience with that
individual people play with it or
I saw it on the website it
is actually primarily intended that
whole groups teams play with it how
is your experience so far yes thanks for
asking so first of all it is
really also intended for groups because
there is a certain social component
is part of it and I think it's also
important because of what we've done so far,
so we've also
accompanied what we've seen with an empirical study,
and that's exactly what we've done for this
study with 500 people
in various
simulation runs  Not all of them in
a simulation
and were able to take a lot away from it.
Otherwise, it is
currently being played through even more in smaller
circles, also in cooperation with
associations and companies,
and it gives you an experience that you
have gained from these
playthroughs
there are too many,
so it's really about the
results that we've collected,
yes, I have to be a bit
cautious
because we've already seen that things are going in
the right direction, in certain
aspects, a psychological
distance can be reduced,
we can say with relative certainty
you don't start acting just because
you do it, we didn't expect that either,
but of course there is always the hope
that you will
bring about a change to a certain extent it could also
strengthen the collective assumed effectiveness among the participants less
self-efficacy because maybe then
But noticed okay my influence is
not that big with what I
can change now and that's where
the further development comes in. Yes
what I only have to say is that we
already had a relatively large
sample but it's rather small  to
very small effects it is
unfortunately always a bit difficult
when you carry out this type of study
and then you may not
get exactly the result you
want, at least we can only say with
the normal certainty that we
always want
that
older people in particular have reacted significantly
with a reduction in
social distance to climate change, so
for them it has now
become more tangible that they themselves
will perhaps still be affected
by climate change,
thank you very much Alexander Hütte
[applause]
may I now, we’ll come in a moment  yet
another game project but before that
I may introduce Birgit Schneider and
welcome I have already worked with Birgit Schneider
on a project
like imagine climate change communication
Birgit Schneider is a professor at the
University of Potsdam for
knowledge cultures and media environment and
you can compare that to us
maybe explain right away what you
can imagine by that otherwise
may I add very briefly she
is perhaps one of the specialists in
Germany for dealing
with pictures, visual language and visual
consideration of
climate issues she studied art science
and media theory and
has also done practical work with  pictures and
design she worked as a
graphic designer herself
published a book four years ago
called climatic pictures and yes that is,
so to speak, the visual approach to the
topic
and now please explain to us again
what knowledge cultures and media
environments are, yes, because
ultimately  In climate communication
and when talking about climate change,
other disciplines are often more at
the microphones, namely psychology in the
social sciences,
fortunately now too, and
of course the natural sciences and
I am a cultural scientist and
have been looking at the topic
from a slightly different perspective for many years
I do research on media in a broad sense,
I look at pictures, films,
computer games, art, but also
instruments, scientific pictures
and how these media shape our reality
and I've looked at
how actually in the sciences we
've already seen before,
these so-called abstract pictures like
that actually allow or have allowed us,
as in western science, to
discover climate change as an object at all and I was very
fascinated by the power of these images
because they actually make data that are not very
clear visible at all
and I then have my topic
in the  Time has expanded over the years
because I also noticed that
ultimately what you said earlier
also happened to the climate facts
over the last eleven years
I have shifted my focus
more and more to cultural
issues and actually which pictures and
Stories are already inside us
in our cultures, for
example in German culture as
one that has a lot to do with Christian values
and biblical ideas and
why, for example,
the apocalypse always appears in the headlines and what
that actually means about us as a society
says that we always
take this interpretative framework and also
press the message of climate change onto it
and why we are actually so well practiced in
thinking about catastrophes and we
find it so fascinating Hollywood films
prove that yes and the project that I
would like to present today and
I was in the  otherwise said or I
misunderstood I should only
bring two slides so there will
only be two slides here from me
although I actually had many pictures is a
that is something I did with Alexander
Schindler who is also here a conference
that we  actually planned for
2020 and as we all know,
conferences could not take place
and then we thought how can
we actually make this conference more sustainable
and started
conducting interviews with the people
we wanted to invite
or with people who  if I
could invite them because they were very far away,
and from that a platform was
created that contains eight interviews,
again I think there is a
natural scientist involved, but
otherwise people from the
natural literary sciences from
philosophy who
give very different contributions as to
why it is actually so difficult
to think for the climate crisis, so we have
already learned a lot about the emotional
hurdles today, but to what extent this
is also a crisis of imagination and
a crisis of culture and the platform
is called imagine climate change
communication and we just
started with the idea that we
yes, we are specifically looking for people or voices to
bring together people who expand our frame of reference
here, for example we have
Nicole Samur, an
American
literary scholar who asked the question
why we actually
assume that certain feelings
are appropriate when we
talk about climate change, the species crisis
and others  not and who then also
collected a lot of humorous examples to
bring in the humor as a
moment of opening for this topic
where we always assume we
all have to mourn now of course yes
and which feelings
are actually being repressed here at the point
or Rita Bracher  The one you see here
is an anthropologist from Delhi who,
in a completely
different cultural framework, also
looks at how
climate change plays a role there, especially for women,
and how this affects various topics
such as who has access to
I would now like to
introduce the effects of water to Ines, who particularly
fascinated me during the interviews
talked to us about very different philosophical paradigms
or how the role of
scientific knowledge in her country,
like what is hit by violent storms,
has thousands of islands,
100 languages ​​and is a very Christian-
Catholic country in part, and she
researched why  the
storm warnings sometimes don't even
reach the people and what also prevents the
religious ideas of the people from getting
to safety
because the warnings are being made the
scientific warnings are being
made these texts are
communicated on point placarded on the radio
but it leads  again and again
to the fact that communities have not brought themselves to
safety because,
based on religious ideas, they
had the opinion that God will have
wanted it that way in order to exacerbate it now
and insofar as I think I
am already at the end of the five
minutes I have  I invite you to
look around on this portal. All the videos
are stored on Youtube
and can also be viewed on
our website in a nicer frame,
I think. There are
also impulse texts that
show us what medicine can help us
and how  we communicate the topic differently,
i.e. if you
think of it medically if you think of it with
scenarios if you think of it as
phenomenology
and yes
that was what I wanted to present today thank you
very
much [applause] thank you Birgit Schneider so we take
our thinking about the
climate crisis with us  is not only characterized by
psychological processes and bices
but also by what we
can think culturally but the title says like
imagine there is maybe something
changeable so now we already have
quite a lot of
science groups lined by
the natural sciences the
social sciences the
cultural sciences and this one's own
would not be complete without the technology and
engineering that
Vera Otter stands for she is a professor at the
Technical University of Berlin and
heads the department of
circular economy and
recycling technology there she also
brought a game with her and what I think is so great
about her topic actually starts with
dealing with the environment  and
climate for a lot of people
with the garbage or with the waste and
insofar exciting that you also
get in there please trash games
thank you very much for the opportunity
to speak here today I am
neither a
communication scientist nor a
climate scientist also our game
or our topic what we or our
topic  what we have processed in a game,
namely the topic of waste in the
crash games, has
not so much to do with climate protection at first,
but maybe we can
come back to that later we have
done a project together with colleagues
from the Humboldt  University,
which is then all mentioned here
as part of the
Bua
project group on the subject of
science communication, and we
had a so-called
short-track project that runs for more than a year
and we have an almost finished
prototype, the research result pressed to
six by ten by four centimetres,
which I  I also brought
[music] with me,
we had seen the call for proposals
on the subject of
science communication and
actually thought it sounds
interesting to us, we've never done anything there before
but would like to do more
and and we also saw it as a bit of an
idea, maybe
competences  the requirement of
the castle was that at least two boa
partners had to come together somehow
that the docking should be on ongoing
projects in a certain sense and
precisely and there was somehow the
possibility to apply for a one-year
or a three-year project
we had it for a one-year at the time  We
made a project and with the
background of
waste management as a circular economy,
we thought okay, maybe something can be done about it,
which maybe
a
step back to this topic of
circular economy,
I think it’s a
communication that was a very interesting
aspect, climate protection was always  is so
a bit cumbersome
negatively, you have
managed to create something with the term for kill
economy
that almost everyone can identify with
waste-trash come
somehow to create something which is positive
everyone who will also
hear physicists already know that
perpetuum mobile does not work and
that circuits
cannot run indefinitely without something and
against the background we might also find it
interesting again as
communication topic to implement this change
from a linear form of economy to
a circular system but under
planetary boundaries
I'm just taking a look right now
maybe very briefly so we have
the tu-partner and my
area of ​​expertise was the circular economy the
hu-partner was then
anthropologists the
almost at the Institute for Ethnology, which
brought the topic of play there in particular, so the
idea of ​​bringing us to this topic of
science communication
and what united us was actually
a place of research where it was actually
not about global topics in a relatively concrete way,
but rather  there were very non-local actions,
namely the House of Statistics here two
subway stations further south at
Alexanderplatz is a
pilot project here in Berlin for
participatory urban redevelopment where an old
GDR institute for statistics is being converted
into various functions of the
town hall in the middle  moving in there
affordable living
certain housing will be created but
also spaces for social
activities and during this
renovation phase in
the pilot pole from the statistics there are
already pioneer use so-called
pioneer use and many
revolve around the topic of
recycling management that was our
starting point and about the house of
Statistics, we then also had
contact with colleagues from the
Humboldt University, who also
have other projects there in the House of Statistics, we have a dbu project there and they have
already done other projects there, that
was kind of the starting point
for the  the anthropoleum of
the university also brought in the medium of games
and that was also the medium
with which we first got to know each other
because the entire application phase was in
full lockdown we were able to
get to know each other digitally, so we didn’t even know
our research partners and
then in that  Summer was something like that in
2020, I think, where you
could meet briefly outside, then got to
know each other through games by simply
playing through the many games on the subject of waste but also climate protection, from very
complex old games from the
80s to Frederik Vester copuli  towards
newer games for different
everyday groups that was the starting point
for the
research process and that was
actually also that it was interesting
then to look at the topic of
waste and circular economy with anthropologists
we
looked at different places in Berlin where
the circular economy is operated in different
forms  from
social
institutions such as the Textilhafen of the
Berlin City Mission to the
waste incineration plant in Ruhleben, and
we not only looked at things in these places, but
also talked to the people who work there
and also their
relationship to the materials
they work with there  have to do with implementing but
also with all the initiatives that
make reuse repairs in the house of statistics that was one of the
places we looked at from which
we
developed various prototypes and
developed the test game in several rounds and
found that when playing
actually quite  many
communication processes take place and
then built them more and more
into this game and
those were just the places
where we were with people and the
interesting thing was that with
these we
first played separately with different groups of actors
and then  also played together with these groups of actors,
i.e.
those actors who normally
have little to do with each other, such as
from a social department store and
the technical manager of the
waste incineration plant, who initially have
very different interests per se in Herrent,
what then came out is this is like
a
card game  with a game board and
where different waste cards for which
you
need qualifications for which you first
have to acquire in the course of the game with which
you have to do something, either
donate them, sell them or
recycle them or play them in the
waste incineration plant and so
the quintessence is that is a
participative game is where you
either
win everyone or lose everyone and you
lose when you either
have no more money or have emitted too much CO2
that's a bit of a link
to climate protection here also in the game
we're still in the last design
Steps and
then that's the overall result and
I think you can draw a few
things out of it on the subject of
science communication on the one hand
very specifically for the circular economy on the
other hand maybe also for the
methodology of using the
medium game and then maybe a
little bit  as an outlook, how can you
continue to work with it and we also see
the game as a
communication tool and not so much
as a training tool
[applause]
then may I ask the
experts here to come up to
the front of the stage again,
so that's how I feel,
I think Birgit page  who
organized this event did a
really great job because there are
so many red threads on the
stage that we could work our way along
unfortunately we have such a small
problem we have a lot of great
thoughts and ideas but not that
much anymore  Time, that's why I would
suggest
we
try to come up with a thesis
that I've written down here,
I've heard that
tipping points are important social
tipping points, I think everyone here would
nod their heads if not then
you can
disagree vigorously and we want to  we're
talking here about
science communication or about
communication and apparently this communication can
help us in some way to help us get to these social
tipping points where things suddenly
become dynamic yes where society
notices a bit like the smoking ban oh it wasn't like that at all  bad
we did something there or with
women's suffrage or with the abolition
of corporal punishment we already have everything
on the list of achievements
and in climate protection something should also
be possible there so the question is how can
science communication now
make contributions what is missing there  you have
so many ideas and approaches but
apparently yes the tipping points are
perhaps only difficult to remove
that you don’t know exactly beforehand
but what more do you wish for from
science communication
who likes it who has an
answer yes Birgit
exactly you  you can just access it
automatically works exactly I found it
very exciting the thesis that we
need to talk more and then the question is
how do we talk and who is allowed to have
peace and what do we talk about and I
have to say I always have in recent
years  I have more doubts about how
scientifically the topic
is talked about than I would have to
become a natural scientist first or at least have watched a number of YouTube
tutorials so that I
can appropriately giggle about the climate crisis and as a cultural scientist
I would say no, we need a lot
more, so I would
but I would say we need a lot
more other spaces in which we can
talk about these topics and maybe
sometimes quite unscientifically about
the feelings about the stories that are
associated with them, also about the
fears about the hopes and that's why
I would say that's just it
transdisciplinary and on all levels
of culture it has to happen
who has to create these spaces
ultimately we all and everywhere so
I think there is nothing of exception
because the climate issue
is not a niche issue across the board but it runs
through everything I wish for the
same in  so if we
maybe break it down to school again,
I don't think that
geography, if it's still called
geography today, is the place where we
should discuss the subject alone,
but that it should also be taught in
German lessons with fiction as a small
or in  So
you can break down the climate topic for each of these blocks,
and I would also
consider all cultural places, theater, music and so on, to be absolutely suitable for this. You have now addressed the role of the
natural sciences, so
the classic form of presentation too  NGO
people who want climate protection is
first of all to
show what is happening in the physical climate and then say okay,
now we have to do this service
I'll ask the psychologist here on
the podium this strong the tone of
science scientific
expertise you just mentioned the
critical concept of distance
put on stage
maybe that also creates distance I mean
60 70 percent of the population
hasn’t had much to do with science in their everyday life
or in their whole life
maybe they don’t even have positive
memories of natural sciences in
class what does it do how  How do
you see that on the one hand,
I think you should look at how
the research works on the one hand
and then how we
communicate about it and the research
naturally happens in a way that
is when you look at an abstract of
the paper here  is not directly
emotionally incredibly profound
experience is so in my experience
i think it stays that way for the time being more
a bit a bit uhm yes
interesting on the subject then
of course think about it if you are such a nerd
and find the subject incredibly exciting
but it is  first abstractly the
question is then what is the next
step no because the paper in this form
the scientific process i would
not doubt it now or not
necessarily want to work on it but i
ask it how do i go on from that stage
when the study is finished erm i
I think it's important on the topic of distance,
how can we then reduce it
or how can we even
manage that an emotional closeness
can be built up
is that is emotionally tangible
in the sense of what does that have
to do with my own life what is here in this
paper  and I believe otherwise
most researchers would
not continue their research themselves if
they did not personally at least
understand and understand why that
is just so relevant and also
this topicality, i.e. the here
and now, no, I believe that is very
important to always emphasize  what
concrete contribution studies
can make today, and especially here in the current situation,
to the general question if I'm really
still pondering a bit because I do
n't have the feeling between scientific communication and social tilting and to
the general question how  let's create
social tilt, I would have said
well, we just need a promise,
just a lot of people who
experience collective self-efficacy,
but as I
said, at least all the steps
I have presented lie between talking about scientific information and collective self-efficacy, and I do
n't think it's just science communication
can do that, but we
still need a lot more, among other things,
participatory processes at a
political level, so then there could
be a thesis that we are actually
talking about the wrong question here, that's the
impression I get when I
talk to people from climate science
they think a lot
about how they can communicate even better and more
effectively, but
maybe that's not the
crucial construction site, so when we
look at surveys, people
are very climate-conscious, they
're actually already where we
want them to be  So I'm going to ask
around here a bit again
and perhaps also to the
science communicators who also
wear this hat,
what do you wish for, what, what needs to
happen with you now or
are there things you say
we actually communicate enough  and you want
something political or from other
actors,
I'll take up the question, so I
might find it
very difficult at first about a we and you
and the people already know enough about it,
so I find this framing alone
somehow super difficult because we're
sitting  all in the same boat here there are
people who may have a connection
to the sciences there are people who
have a connection to the soil because they
come from agriculture,
yes, it's not just the
experts who are now
advancing climate science  are
they also aware of our
ore system, so that we also
create a discussion here that
is more or less on an equal footing and also
include different perspectives in this communication and also
make it possible in the first place and
that we, as communicators,
I would say  more from the
academy, try to listen
and really take the time and space
to absorb these impulses because
I think it needs more communication think
better communication whatever that
means, but
above all it just takes a lot of time  and
energy that's just
nothing that you just
do on the side
dealing with the climate crisis is
n't something you do on the side that
's the question of who has the
capacity to do it and
just say there is  now here the
institute and that communicates and then
it's done so I don't believe in that,
but that we
create the spaces in our society
where we can talk about it
but also, for example, in school there is
also the time where you
maybe  has to ask is it so
important now that this and that is now in the
curriculum or can we
take the space and time
to talk about this topic forever,
so I'll take that with us, we
need communication at
eye level, so not that now  the
expertise teach the people out there something
but more participation to
listen to each other but my
impression when i
hear science politicians now
say yes we have to
strengthen science communication but
we are a science country
science location and they have to
make everyone enthusiastic about Mint and  then we will be super
and strong here so
I don't see this gesture in science policy
Ms. Rotter you
have contacted me
okay yes maybe another point besides
the purely communicative one that's
always something audiovio
elle
is an experience from our project for me
also that the experience of being in
places of smelling things
and and and this experience that you
also have completely different
levels of communication about it, so somehow
we have from these visits we
have there now, I would say, completely
new teaching formats where the  that's what we call
walking lectures where we go through places
and just about this
materiality from where is
the sewage treatment plant the
incineration plant the coal-fired power plant
and we have that here in Berlin
and if you do that with children, but
also with students  also
does with adults and
talks about things in these places then it is a lot
a lot I'll say it
more urgently and more lastingly in my
memory than when I hear a lecture
that a kilowatt hour imitates so and so
many co2 equivalents that's
something abstract when I say the
I see piles of coal in Spandau in
Siemensstadt, then I can
perhaps imagine a lot more underneath
and I think we need a lot
more of these
real experiences and not just
audio communication via different
media, yes, they say something like that
works and I think they do in their
project  are also experimenting with such
approaches and Chiara too, so that
obviously works to bring people in to
participate empower to make actors,
then we also have a
climate policy that says yes, we are
not only doing this in
pilot projects here in the Berlin
University Alliance, but also  we do it
across the board and climate policy
means not only talking about coal-fired power plants
but also about massive
education policy at the point
with politics yes that is of
course a large field and from yes
my experience with a lot of
empirical research I am really
convinced that a stop the the
Framework conditions that are also really
important in order to
achieve changes, so it is really
difficult, as I have just seen empirically, to simply change behavior,
which does not mean, from my point of view, that
you should give up trying
and I think these are also
important aspects  you just
said and making something tangible
maybe thinking about a completely different form of
communication and I
honestly come from a little bit of
marketing and think maybe you just have to take a
closer look at how do
you have to communicate in a way that is appropriate to the target group
because people have to be
addressed in very different ways  or
companies in general probably
also know much better how to
address people correctly,
I think you can learn a thing
or two
about climate change
communication because I think we as researchers
are not the
best at selling products and ideas  probably yes, so
when you think of who are you thinking of, who
should learn something, who who
has a special study group,
probably a bit of courage to just
go out and break away
from the dry scientific
seriousness and go into other forms of
communication
I would say games are a
good bridge first and therefore I would like to have more of them
yes and then I'll give them up right away here
some hands twitched you'll get to them
soon I also want to invite the
audience here
to get in touch and so you park
something  you wanted to say and then we have
a request to speak, the lady over there in
row five or six,
hello, I'm from ziegelwellen in terms of quantity
and I just wanted to
add something, so because of this science
communication, for example, we are
also a project laboratory at the TU and
we are also trying to
build bridges
between the science of the academia
and the partner, in addition to bringing the
universities together and also
to motivate citizens to
do what we do at the university, so that
they
can also participate in it themselves  and I think it's
also very important that we don't just
communicate about it, but that
we can also motivate
them to work with us,
because when we say that
Berlin 2014 is climate-neutral5 there are a lot of
measures for mobility in  of the
buildings in the energy and but that that
there must also be the best
examples that
we say everything that in the end we are
now climate-neutral because I have
noticed that we have
implemented a project like this in the schools
to create Kliemann and so all the buildings
and there so went to the
school with the
school with the school manager with the little with the
school management
organized workshops to understand
okay what is the situation in the
building now and is the temperature is
it good  or is it too bright, is it too
dark and how can they actually
save energy in the building, for example, and we
started his communication campaign and for months we
have saved 12% of energy and that's
why I think it's a
bit more not only  comment
but too important as he
said out loud go on site and then
show these measures properly where are
the hardpoints where can we how can
we do it together okay so to speak
go out into the city where the real
things can be changed thank you very much yes
Hello hello, I would
like to add that from my
perspective, creating social tipping points
is really about
strengthening transformation skills,
so just information that what
science communication can
do is simply limited is
not enough, it's about the
skills we have  and if we
have a lot of people who have the
skills to
drive forward transformation themselves, whether that’s
climate communication or something else, but
we really get into practice, we
get into action and then tell other people,
then I think we’ll create
this dynamic system and this
positive reinforcement that we need
a room in which people
can try something are enthusiastic
really want to do something but
we also need the
appropriate framework conditions so where
are the rooms currently who has the time
who has the peace and quiet to
deal with them at best that’s what
you really  can also take time off
or be taken off time
so it's really a space to have a
transformative effect yourself and if that's
cool if that's fun if that
inspired me if I can use the
vehicle wow but for the first time in my
life  I really make a difference then I
think we really create social
tipping points because then I continue to tell it
out of passion for what inspires inspiration and then
other people will copy it too,
so I think people will definitely hear me afterwards,
I definitely want to
agree and even if I or we
ourselves also come very much from physics or from
the natural sciences, I would also like
to add that our approaches to
science communication are also based
on appearance and create dialogue with
society. I think
these spaces are super important to
create but also  in the framing
that we also invite people from
different cultures, that we have
different perspectives and that
we really think of
the place where we are, that
is, when we are in Germany we
have certain privileges and so on that
that too  flows into these
spaces because we have a
very
limited perspective and we
therefore also need a plurality
in these spaces and erm I think
this is a fact that is often
forgotten but which is very important
because then often there is
a lot going on in politics as well  being pushed outside
and getting into other countries
and we need these perspectives, too,
we have to be aware of what is
happening to what, in any case, Transis, the
plinarity on many levels, so I want to
take up this keyword, spaces,
that it sounds a bit abstract
we have  I think there was
a good experience in Germany with an
experience called the EEG, so at the beginning of the
2000s the EEG gave people the
opportunity to get together in their
village in their local community
relatively easily, to
found cooperatives and to
make the energy transition that became  then
death regulated so that these
cooperatives
could hardly live self-efficacy so that is a very real
thing these rooms
because there is an audience there is a request to speak
maybe raise your hand again so that
the microphone can move there in the
interim question someone wanted to
add quite directly
I  I still have a question because
last week I sat down with a woman who
is part of the Science Rebellion.
She said we don't need to
write any more, actually no
longer communicate, now we have to
act, that's what
we're all exposed to and what I am
Self-efficacy would also be of interest, yes, but how do we
deal with the fact that in
political activity, now
again in Egypt, this
activity on the level
is actually not really tangible and how do
we translate that into our feelings and
who accompanies us  so there
alone the next um yes CO2 value of
Germany to digest for the year 2022
so that's sometimes such
a discrepancy that I feel and where I do
n't know an answer to it yes yes thank you
also helplessness is allowed
please
yes I would have the question  I found
everything about
science communication super exciting, but I
asked myself is there a specific
target group or do you think there is a
specific target group that we have to
address now that things have to be done quickly
or is it about reaching a broad
mass?  Yes, also about
social tipping points, so we
simply have to reach as many people as possible
in a short time, or should we
rather focus on a specific group
in order to bring about as much
change as possible in a short time,
thanks for the question
in terms of expectation management if
there are any other questions in the  audience
we connect then we answer
the questions then we have
a very concise final round
there are more questions from the
audience please there in the middle
two more questions
I’ll just start thank you very much
for the input definitely me  I think
the climate debate is very emotional
and charged and very polarizing
and my question is how communication
climate communication can work better
to counteract this polarization
within society, which
is ultimately back at the social tipping point and where then the emotions
of many people the  are very
negative with me but I would like to
continue to fly on vacation or I do
n't want to restrict myself now how
can I take up that in any rooms
so the question of polarization
yes thank you very much for the nice contributions
my question is the Fridays for
future-  movement that's a
social tipping point they did
n't work it out that well
hundreds of thousands took to the streets
before Corona or my way
now also after Corona did that have an
impact on awareness or what's missing
what else needs to happen thank you very much yes
three questions
go  we go through them one after the other or
can you just tell us something about all the
questions that would be an
option if you would like to say something yes
you are welcome yes I like the questions very much
because for me they
address sticking points in the climate communication debate and
I think all three might
first the question of the target group, so who
should we actually reach,
um
[music]
I only have a two-part answer,
on the one hand, we have to keep talking to everyone
in order to
really remain in dialogue later on about polarization,
then not at all with a specific goal
in the sense of what we want  now that this
target group is doing XYZ, but to
come together again, to keep up the dialogue,
to stay in touch with each other at all,
the second answer
is, of course, we can also take a
strategic approach and then I would
say definitely do a
target group segmentation like this, I don't know
tomorrow  there were six social types that came to watch back then,
that
the sixth I would say
distributed relatively evenly, uh, what I
find the most exciting and now
actually very politically urgent is
the disappointed people, and
I think the term says
a lot  this is a kind of labeling that will
come from tomorrow to
describe the target group people who
feel left behind or
are really left behind, so they are also socially
autonomous and maybe
look a little deeper into it don't
give a lecture now the second question of
polarization that's where I think it is
a best practice example for me actually
citizens’ councils so very practical to
reduce political polarization by
getting involved no not just
through communication I don’t know I
try
to address all sorts of people but to
create real participation and that’s where we are right
now I’d say in
really involve citizens in councils in such a pilot phase in
such a way that they
can also achieve something that is very important in
participation, not only to make participation to this day,
but that in the
end the people
were really involved in a real
decision-making process, um and maybe
also  because it's interesting tomorrow
we'll come and take a look because their
customers' motivation is actually
to strengthen social cohesion
and
they do their work out of that motive  there
was a big momentum that
felt like a tipping point and I
like that maybe you can
keep that momentum going
it's definitely a social tipping
point we can't
deny that it's great what Greta Thunberg
has accomplished in a really short amount of time
But it is a social tipping point that has
perhaps not yet had a
strong impact on the climatic tipping points,
so that's just it,
but it's like a chain reaction, so that
's for example because
it has received so much media attention,
for example with The
Guardian everywhere now  says we
will always say something about the climate crisis
that it has brought to other levels that
definitely but
it is not just a social
tipping point because we have to create real consequences so that there
are really real consequences but
we really see that  how doing something
also brings something
yes we have to
bring these discussions to a conclusion
I would like to try to get to the point
we also have
climate communication in the Paris Agreement,
there is Article 12,
Article 12 says the contracting parties,
so the states
take measures  for information for
education for training for
raising awareness for
access to information and for participation
so there are a lot of keywords that
were here today and please
say each one if you
think of Article 12 what you wish for
in the case of politics  In order to help
this program achieve a breakthrough,
Ms. Rotter,
please start with what was
said earlier that this this
is a lot of education and
social support too, what I
would wish for is perhaps that
research funding is not segmented either
of
social activities that simply this
division of departments like we have in the
ministry and in the allocation of funds because it
simply becomes more transparent
if you have an idea or not
somehow from one door to another then
you have to ask or ask
questions or do that  ask because you
are somewhere in between,
yes, I would underline the
mixing of different
disciplines and also of approaches to the
topic, which are absolutely essential
and since no more voices are no
longer to be trusted than others, i.e.
nobody to give the song like that and
at the same time  I also have to say that I
would always be a bit careful
with this call for
positive stories because I think
we also have to recognize that we
humans are not stupid, so it
's not a positive story and
I think finding the balance is about that
to endure and still
be positive or to take the risk of
retaining hope, too, there must be room for that too, I'll pass on
briefly
how I would implement Article 12 better
actually that I was good and
that's the nice thing about the Paris
Agreement now you can  think big
People would share with each other who
deal with the climate crisis from their very own context I
think first of all a good friend of mine
Pablo from the Philippines will share
with a board member of the German
DAX group and they both have the
task together  to think about
what is which
experience, what experiences do I bring with me on the subject of the
climate crisis and how can we both,
together with the very different
resources and perspectives that we have,
actually implement something in the subject of trade,
um corresponding communication,
really get people to do something in
a framework that is inviting  and
then really let the power they have be used
yes thank you now I have to interject briefly
that eskiara also
had an idea to let people from very
different parts of the world
come together in a simulation
to then
exchange experiences in the climate future
otherwise would  I would also like to
say something again and say that education is
somehow important, also to
create trust, which has perhaps
already been lost in some places, so
the foundations are
perhaps laid in childhood,
you can say that it is
almost like that for the coming generation  a
little later, but it's
important to keep optimism and
smart goals, so maybe just
celebrate the small successes, even if it does
n't work now with 1.5 degrees, every
tenth degree can maybe save lives,
uh,
for me, maybe a prioritization
of this communication and
honesty  how much resources that
eats up, as well as, for example, in interdisciplinary
and transdisciplinary projects,
a large part of the time is wasted, I would say, first of all,
so that you first
have to find a common language and
maybe also
be honest in a scientific system,
maybe sometimes  to set content goals
down a bit and
really take the time to
deal with each other to listen to each other
thank you very much yes more clearly Rodrigues
you still want to add
no we are
driving it is really difficult for me right now
so to go message I
hope that this is here  what has brought and
that we simply continue to go beyond our
limits and think yes, you
have definitely given us a lot of
ideas and very positive impulses thank
you very much for this
wonderful podium
[applause] many
thanks also to the technology and
[applause]
to the organizers  and organizers
of the climate lab and the glasses science
week and many thanks to you and also
for the fact that we can talk about these things together let's
keep talking we heard that
's a very important first step
and we won't stop there I
wish  have a wonderful good
evening thank you
[applause]